-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Gonna be fun.
Well, guys, today,
nominations were announced for
the 64th annual Grammy Awards.
That's right.
Both Billie Eilish
and her brother, Finneas,
were nominated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
So I just want to say good luck
to their cousins
Talking about their jobs
at Thanksgiving.
Olivia Rodrigo's
"drivers license" was nominated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you know
it's been a long 2021.
People were thinking,
"That came out this year?"
Yeah, the Grammys
will be on CBS,
which means the only
nominee that viewers
will be familiar with is ABBA.
"I know -- Yeah, I love ABBA."
Well, earlier tonight,
President Biden
and the First Lady
arrived in Nantucket, where
they'll spend Thanksgiving.
That's how bad
Thanksgiving traffic is.
Even the president
has to leave two days early.
Good luck to us.
Yeah, once Biden
left for Thanksgiving,
the Secret Service was like,
"Human Tryptophan
is on the move."
When Biden asked Obama
if Martha's Vineyard
would be nice for Thanksgiving,
Obama was like,
"Uh...you should
check out Nantucket."
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling Biden's
the only person who says,
"I once knew a man
from Nantucket"
and then tells an
actual story about that man.
[ As Biden ]
He was a longshoreman.
Named Gary Finster.
[ Normal voice ]
But this is nice.
Before they left for Nantucket,
First Lady Jill Biden
received The White House
Christmas tree.
Take a look at this.
[ "O Tannenbaum" playing ]
Yeah.
-Look how beautiful this is.
It's beautiful.
-Yeah. You know gas prices
are out of control when
they're sending things to
The White House
via horse and carriage.
[ Imitates whip cracking ]
Come on!
Come on, buddy!
Come on there, buddy!"
[ Laughs ]
That was amazing improvisational
skills on all of our part.
You were doing --
-Yeah, yeah.
-"Come on, buddy."
-[ Imitates whip cracking ]
-"Come on, now."
Pbht!
-Oh!
-Meanwhile, Trump
was hiding in the branches
like a Trojan horse,
waiting to sneak back inside
The White House.
♪♪
Speaking of Trump, I saw that,
over the weekend at Mar-a-Lago,
he received his honorary
9th-degree black belt
in Tae Kwon Do.
[ Laughter ]
This is real.
Take a look. Here he is.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Tying that around Trump
must have been like
tying a giant red bow
around a Lexus.
You know?
You ever seen those commercials?
It was the first time
they had to
cut a few extra holes in
a Tae Kwon Do belt.
Yeah, Trump
is big into martial arts.
He's even starring in
the new movie
"Crouching Tiger,
Hidden Tax Returns."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Hey!
Hey, oh!
-Well, this went viral
last night.
The Washington Wizards
played the Charlotte Hornets,
but all anyone could talk about
was Wizards star Kyle Kuzma's
pregame outfit.
Watch this.
Wow.
He looks like a rejected
character from "Yo Gabba Gabba!"
He looks like someone who said,
"I don't need to try it on.
I'll just buy it."
-Yeah.
-Meanwhile, Lenny Kravitz's
scarf saw that
and was like, "Well, hello!"
♪♪
"Hello, there. Hi."
[ Laughs ]
And, finally, I saw that a very
unique Christmas-tree display
has returned to
a mall in Canada.
Some people think it's cute,
while others think
it's a little creepy.
Here, check it out.
-Oh!
-Well, now we know what the
Christmas episode of
"Squid Game" will look like.